now to france where president emmanuel
macron won re-election last night over a
far right-wing opponent maureen lepen
voters gave macron a substantial victory
in a runoff that was expected to be very
close elaine cobb is covering the
election in paris and elaine the
significance of this vote goes far
beyond france
yes there were sighs of relief across
much of france and beyond as macron's
victory ended the chances of an
extremist president with close ties to
russia and hostile to nato
president macron's supporters counted
down to victory under the eiffel tower
[Applause]
where his post-election party continued
into the night
won more than 58
against le pen's 41 percent the closest
the far right has come to taking the top
seat in france we stood up against
nationalism and we try to show that
today we have to be united more than
ever
[Music]
but his celebration will be short-lived
this election has shown deep divisions
that macro acknowledged in his victory
speech
we need to be respectful he said our
country is full of so many doubts so
many divisions so we will need to be
strong but no one will be left behind
macron will have a tough job uniting the
french behind him this election showed
extremist voters far outnumbered those
from the center or the traditional left
and right parties
after the result there were protests in
several cities against both candidates
fireworks were launched at the police
tear gas was used to clear crowds one
banner called mackerel the robin hood of
the rich
le pen echoed that sentiment
to avoid this hoarding of power by a few
she said i will continue my commitment
to france
in an increasingly fractured country le
pen vows to fight on
congratulations have been pouring in
from around the world including from
president biden and ukraine's vladimir
zielinski macron's real fight now will
be at home gail
all right elaine cobb reporting from
paris we thank you